For all the times that you would rain on my parade,...
...and all the clubs you get in using my name.
You think you broke my heart, oh boy, for goodness' sake.
You think I'm crying on my own, well I ain't.
And I didn't wanna write a song...
...'cause I didn't want anyone thinking I still care, I don't...
...but you still hit my phone up.
And baby, I'll be moving on.
And I think you should be something I don't wanna hold back.
Maybe you should know that.
My mama don't like you and she likes everyone.
And I never like to admit that I was wrong.
I've been so caught up in my job, didn't see what's going on...
...and now I know, I'm better sleeping on my own.
'Cause if you like the way you look that much,...
...oh baby, you should go and love yourself.
And if you think that I'm still holding on to something,...
...you should go and love yourself.